[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon is based on
the georgia or martin's targaryen
history book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon the
third's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
when people speak about aegon's conquest
people always speak how it's
aegon and his sister wives rhaenyra and
with zegna who conquered and united the
seven kingdoms
but they forget to mention their
half-brother born out of wedlock
or is baratheon son of aryan targaryen
oris played just as big role in aegon's
conquest
he might not have ridden a dragon which
he most certainly would have
if there had been a fourth dragon as he
was the blood of a dragon himself
but he commanded aegon's armies on the
ground as
aegon the conqueror said it himself oris
was his shield
his stalwart his strong right hand why
was oryis a baratheon and not a
targaryen you may ask
velarys and aegon had the same father
aryan targaryen
but different mothers and unlike aegon's
mother orys's mother did not vet their
father
therefore oryis could not get the
targaryen surname as he was born out of
wedlock
how and why the doris get baratheon's
surname is unknown
but it's likely that baratheon's surname
was used in malaria for children born
out of wedlock like snow
sand and a few more are used for
children born out of wedlock investors
lord doris baratheon was the founder of
house baratheon and was half
brother of king aegon the first
targaryen that's right
first baratheon was blood of the dragon
half targaryen himself
orys was one of aegon's fiercest
commanders and was regarded as aegon's
only true friend and champion of his
youth
during the war of conquest he was a
commander in the army of fagon the
conqueror
when aegon invaded vestrios he sent oris
to seed storm's end
the ancestral seat of the storm kings
and capital of the stormlands
oris defeated the storm king argu lagged
the arrogant and took not only storm's
end
but also his sigil the crowned black
stag
and words ours is the fury as well as
his daughter argila
and his sword to cement his rule over
the stormlands
he became the first lord paramount of
auris is also considered the first hand
of the king serving gig on the conqueror
famed for his prowess in battle his
commanding skills
and his strong loyalty to king aegon the
first and house targaryen
orys was described as a fierce warrior
fighting for house targaryen during
aegon's conquest
the first dornish more and the vulture
hunt
being the founder of house baratheon
oris baratheon is the distant ancestor
of king robert baratheon and his
brothers
stannis and renly oris had black hair
and black eyes
as well as black beard in game of
thrones if you paid close attention you
could notice that he has an entry in the
lineages and histories of the great
houses of the seven kingdoms
it reveals soros's marriage to arjula
and that one of his sons
died stopping an assassination attempt
against the son of his half-brother
aegon the conqueror
king gaine is targaryen little is known
about his youth
but what is known is that orys was
aegon's champion
when king argually randon offered aegon
his daughter arjula in marriage and some
lands as her dowry
the lord of dragonstone aegon spurned
the storm king's proposal
instead he requested significantly more
land and offered to seal the pact by
wetting oris to
argilec's daughter the storm king
angrily rejected these terms
for argue like the arrogant believed
that this was supposed to be an insult
for oris
might have been aegon's brother and have
targaryen blood
but taurus was born out of deadlock and
the storm king viewed such a match would
dishonor his daughter
anger that the insult of being offered a
man born out of adlock instead of a king
argilac cut off the hands of aegon's
envoys
when aegon's conquests had begun oris
had command on the ground during the
first battle
defeating lords mouton and darkling oris
led the army while aegon attacked from
the skies
after aegon's coronation at aegon fort
orys was raised to hand of the king
within days of the coronation oris and
queen rhaenys targaryen with her dragon
myrixis were then tasked
with capturing storm's end taking the
greater part of fagon's host with them
while king argilac gathered his banners
lord svel buckler and
errol ambushed the advanced elements of
orys's host
until they were forced to retreat and
marxists burned the surrounding woods
arguing like the arrogant hearing of the
burning of harrenhal
knew his formidable walls would not
protect him from dragonfire
argilac rode out with his great hosts to
give open battle and die with a sword in
hand
orys was made aware of argilac's march
by rhaenys
who provided him with the storm king's
numbers and dispositions
for she had spotted the host with her
dragon baratheon took up a strong
position on the hills south of
bronzegate
digging in on the high ground while he
evaded the stormlanders
argelek's host was twice the size of
orisis
and when the battle called the last
storm begun the stormlanders managed to
break through the baratheon's center
only to be engulfed by dragonflame with
marxists and reinies turning the battle
into chaos
or is descended down the hill where he
encountered the storm king
ordering his own men to stand aside he
gave argilac a chance to yield
argilac cursed stories and they fought
instead
although he took wound or is slow
arguing the arrogant ending the reign of
the storm kings
the loss of their king made the
stormlanders surrender or flee
after the battle argela the random the
daughter of argilac
declared herself the storm queen and
continued to hold storm's end until her
household
turned against her to avoid the same
fate of harrenhal
they delivered her towards naked and
chained
oris however covered her with his cloak
and treated her chivalrously
aegon rewarded oris with the lands and
incomes of storm's end
and named him lord paramount of the
stormlands none dared suggest that he
was unworthy of these honors
oris to cardiologize his wife and to
honor argilac's valor he adopted the
stag banner
honors and words of the durandans ours
is the fury
forming house baratheon oris later
joined king aegon the first in the first
dornish war in 4ac
leading an assault on the boneway with 1
000 pig knights
his horses struggled up the stoney
narrow and twisty paths
while his knights were hit with boulders
from above the work of defenders the
stormlanders never saw
cunning dornishmen then launched a night
raid raining arrows rocks and spears
from above
as the stormlanders crossed the bridge
bodies of the invading army blocked the
bone wave from both ends
and when lord doris ordered his men to
fall back
a triggered rock fall cut off their
retreat with no way forward or back
the stormlanders were massacred save for
oris and a dozen
other lords thought worth the ransom
however oris and his bannermen found
themselves the captives of the ville of
vel
the savage mountain lord called the bit
of lover when aegon eventually agreed to
the dornish ransom demands lord
baratheon and his bannermen were
ransomed in 7ac
for each men's weight in gold however
they were afraid only after having their
sword hands chopped off
so they would not be able to use them
again against dorne
thereafter oris became known as zorris
one hand
in retaliation for this treachery king
aegon descended on the mountain fastness
of house well
with his dragon valerian and burned them
to rubble although the wills managed to
take refuge in their caves and tunnels
beneath the mountains
after the loss of his hand in the first
dornish war oris became bitter
turning his attention to dorne and
obsessed with the idea of revenge
he resigned his office as hand and
returned to the stormlands
while resigning he is set to aegon the
king's hand should have a hand
i will not have men speaking of king's
stump he became
obsessed with vengeance against the
dornish especially house well
whose lord had removed his hand vampire
says deria martel came to king's landing
to provide peace terms
lord doris argued for sending the
princess back to her father nymore the
prince of dorne without a hand
but aegon made peace with dorne instead
oris received his opportunity for
vengeance against the villas in the
second dornish war
during the early reign of aegon's son
king gaines the first targaryen
in 37ac a dornish outlaw known as the
vulture king led a huge army to reeve
the lands north of the red mountains
the vulture king split his host having
one half
led by lord walter well the lord of
storms and orris
eager for revenge against the dornish
led his forces from storm's end one last
time to participate in the vulture hunt
while will's host sat besieging
stonehelm
orys's forces crushed the dornish man
beneath the walls of the castle
lord walter will the son of will who
chopped off or is his hand was brought
to worse
wounded but still alive your father took
my hand
i claim yours as repayment or he said to
him but he took far more
lord baratheon chopped off walter's
sword hand then his other hand
followed by both feet which he called
his usury or in other words his
prolonged revenge
with interest at unreasonably high rates
on his trip home to storm zen legendary
oris died of the wounds he had taken in
the battle
or his died content according to his son
davos smiling that he got his revenge
or his baratheon blood of the dragon
played a huge role in aegon's conquest
and is one of the most important
characters from this time period
an honorable man who upholds his loyalty
to his half-brother aegon
and whose prowess in battle was greater
even of that of fagon himself
which he proved in the war against the
last storm king and whose commanding
skills earned aegon to conquer
quite a few important victories in
westeros can we just take a moment to
say that this baratheon crown
suits henry cavill very well huge strong
man with black hair and good
swordsmanship
like a true baratheon just perfect
choice for auris baratheon
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace